all right so I want to talk about what
happens when you overeat now this
probably has never happened to you but
you may know people who do overeat
occasionally now there's two situations
you have people that are doing in a
minute fasting and keto and they're
overeating because they're basically not
going to eat for 18 hours and they're
like freaking out like oh my gosh I'm
going to starve so I have to eat so much
to last that long
if that's your situation then what you
need to do is you need to just keep a
log and write down how you feel after
you stuff yourself so the next time that
you do this you'll realize wow that was
very painful I better eat a little bit
less and then what happens is get used
to that so you have the confidence to go
longer and longer and longer and fast
and you'll realize that you're not going
to starve to death and then you have
people that are not on the keto plan and
not doing in a minute fasting and
they're definitely in a trap because
what happens is that though they might
go to a restaurant for example and they
bring out the bread they consume the
bread even before you even start you
know eating your main meal then you have
their dirt that bring you the alcohol
and then you have the main course right
which always comes with the starch and a
protein in a side salad by that time
you're completely stuffed your tube your
digestive tract is completely packed
down but they're not done they bring you
another document it's called a dessert
menu okay and then you're gonna have a
dessert I mean it's so normal
everyone does it I don't do it but a lot
of people do it
I see people at restaurants I'm like I
don't know how they did all that food in
their gut and so they eat the dessert
and then they get home and they're just
completely bloated what happens is that
it interferes with their sleep the next
day they feel grouchy they have low
blood sugars they crave carbs then next
day really bad and the whole cycle
starts over and over and over again so
let's take a look at some of the things
that can happen when you'e read number
one you're just resting your digestive
system in general you have all these
different processes that are occurring
with this stomach with the gallbladder
with the pancreas with the small
intestine with the large bowel a lot of
hormonal and things going on and a lot
of these processes are never completed
it's always incomplete because there's
never a time where the that pipe is
empty
it's always full there's always food
coming in so you're gonna get gas
bloating constipation feel nauseous
and you definitely have a spike of
insulin okay and eventually that's gonna
lead to insulin resistance which is
pre-diabetes because you're overworking
that pancreas most the population is
right here but they don't even know it
and there's all these symptoms that go
with this right here you've probably
heard me talk about this a million times
it's going to affect your sleep cause
sleep apnea sleep apnea is insulin
resistance by the way and before it's
gonna overload the fat cell because
you're consuming more calories then you
can use up so it has to go into storage
so you're forcing your body to fill up
the fat cell as much as it can and it
spills over into the liver and around
the organs it's called visceral fat okay
so you eat the meal you spiked the
insulin the high level of insulin pushes
the blood sugar down and you're gonna
feel the next day you're going to have
moodiness and a lot more cravings okay
especially two carbs so realize your
cravings today came from what you ate
yesterday usually and this and you start
the whole cycle again you're in this
trap and you just you just can't get out
of it because you're craving so much you
need to satisfy that sweet tooth then
you get all sorts of inflammatory
conditions okay primarily because the
high levels of insulin there's a certain
enzyme called protein kinase R in your
body that is involved in stress signals
and it protects you against viruses when
you overeat
this enzyme is suppressed it shuts down
and that starts slowing your metabolism
all right so now realize that having
insulin resistance you're gonna have a
hard time pulling nutrients inside your
cell so you're not going to be satisfied
after you eat which is going to cause
the need to continue to eat
there's no shutoff valve because the
cells are resistant to insulin so you
have to get on a plan that corrects this
okay for those of you that are new click
the link down below I will show you what
to do exactly to solve this to the point
where you eat and you actually feel
satisfied which is be a new concept and
then we have intermittent fasting which
is essential because it allows the
intestines to finally get a break and
rest what I would recommend for you is
to make an agreement with yourself that
if you let's say you go off track or you
go off the wagon and you overeat you
just do intermittent fasting longer okay
at least that will actually repair some
of the damage conscious eating even with
people on keto what happens is they get
home and they start watching TV and they
just like start snacking okay and on
nuts and things like that and certain
keto friendly snacks and bars and what
happens is like they're still overeating
maybe it's not bad foods but they're
still overeating so it's a problem so if
you have a problem with this right here
what you may want to do is adjust your
schedule let's say for example it's
really easy for you to fast in the
morning all the way till through the
afternoon all the way till five o'clock
or a six o'clock or even later but let's
say for example your most difficult time
is at night okay you have a just a hard
time saying no to certain foods well
just work your schedule were you fast
all morning afternoon and you're eating
window is that night so it's totally
okay to eat alright so in summary I'm
gonna recommend you really just have to
be more in the present and try not to
slip into this kind of unconscious
eating pain and so many people are
involved with so if you go to a
restaurant and you're socializing just
be more aware of what you're putting in
your body so you make sure you don't
overdo it
alright thanks for watching so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that